pessoal eu acabei de descobrir que aqui
na colômbia é mesmo de trás da casa tem
uma floresta mas não só
olha aí eu não sei onde é que vai dar
esta floresta mas têm aqui hoje eu vim
com olha só
por trás da rede tem muita coisa lá
profunda e eu não sair mas é uma
floresta muito grande o assunto tem
coisas são escolhidas e tem que
investigar isso eu vou fazer um game
chegará explique look que outra coisa
curiosa eu já começa a sentir com uma
idéia para um outro vídeo software em
que ele diga que a floresta por trás da
colômbia como eu tenho muito em baixo
para o investigado mas vamos ouvir
porque se ele vai ser muito especial
o lado pessoal de quem fala ao dar que
sejam muito bem vindos mas um de leogang
o estrago de que um vídeo muito especial
eu vou voar o meu novo animal de
estimação e desde já
este animal tanto pode ser dócil fofo
muito querido como também pode ser
perigoso mas a gente só deixei muito
líquido e feriu-se ajuda muito que o
canal e se você se tornou pequeno canal
eu sou daqui e vocês podem criar aqui
neste botãozinho eles têm estilos muito
obrigado e agora vamos investigar quem
animal perigoso é composta de que em
casa papo eu tenho aqui uma trégua o que
poderá ser um cão um gato um cavalo um
cavalo no contrato
outra coisa que nós temos aqui olha só
spray antiga raça qual é o animal pode
ficar raça cão gato também podem ter
vamos continuar a investigar outra coisa
que eu tenho aqui né é um pente e olha
só que o pinto tempinho branco que
poderá ser um gato branco um cão branco
eu não sei porque tudo direito porque
você já sabe qual é o animal está no
tribunal dar porque tu estás a fazer uma
série de casos uru eu acho que com esta
pista vocês vão descobrir o caso
olha só do corpo qual é o animal que
colocou o campeão o gatilho e não não é
o caso julgado o que será pessoal não
sair mas vamos tentar atrair o perdedor
o nosso animal normalmente ainda assim
uma destas folhagens é muito perigosa
doença ou condição sexual não sei onde é
que eu não sei um pouco escondida pode
matar agora a qualquer momento e não
esconder aqui na floresta e hoje toca eu
fosse mal favore pode lindo olha que
tenho aqui durante varias mesmo
pessoal eu adotei uma cabra né
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bom aí é muito fofo é tão hora e agora
já vem nem quando eu tenho minha por
aqui também podem não fuja
ele acaba ainda como atleta vinha eu
acho que o bode por sua história já viu
né
toma agora toma aqui um ervin aí anda
agora já que não é comida na boca e
toquero comida na boca do cash é mesmo a
escola agora a nossa cultura está
escondido enquanto comem mas ela procura
mais é que está a nossa cultura gosto
muito de comer então mora em encostas
é como andar aqui para sombra porque se
conseguir uma melhor ainda e isso é que
aqui pode comer à vontade lá pra baixo
digam lá se um momento fofo olha só
crime pelo primeiro então já foi embora
agora não posso jurar pra câmera marinel
é dali que o coautor de um cara muito
sério blog que tal fazer bonito e bom
pessoal está um novo membro da colômbia
é uma cabra nigeriana é ela agora que os
cofres cérebro ficasse muito por ele e
deve ser também ela está cheia de
comichão e isso é agora a bola está
ficar bonito olha só eu ou de linda
lutar com meira e tem muita fome igual o
dono é esse bicho já fica grande
simbólica entre peru moderaram as
pessoas não as pessoas podem ainda
ganhar foi de carro a toda hora e
acabado quando eu trouxe aqui pra casa
eu estava muito agitado e vocês vão ver
imagens que agora o
[Música]
ôrí hoje
ó olhe na galiza onde está o roni molhe
bori cantando que ele pode fazer calor
olá bolle
danny boyle
você quer uma senhora ainda bole bole
sol de molly solta mori
quem deixa a desejar fazer olhe quem
pode tocar diz muito
dois dias depois eu conhecer eu
construir uma casinha provisória que vos
mostrar agora olha aí olha essa coisinha
para é só pessoal eu aproveitei que o
canto do meu jardim público jovem é
enorme
o jardim vender de casa a tec e aqui
faixa como se fosse um triângulo né
então eu coloquei que estas cercas e
provisoriamente para a primeira semana
eu construí uma casinha de cão e
colocá-lo em algum filho dentro porque
ela adora comer phenom ii tem é que a
água que era onde o be é claro que já
está suja e eu ainda tentei dar aqui um
pouquinho leite de cabra mas eu não
estou mas tampouco se perceber que eu
tava ficar dócil estava ficar assim
amigável então eu fiz um texto eu vou
deixá-la que assunto por uma semana e
ver o que acontece e eu não pulo por
fora de casa eu fui super amigável ainda
mais amigável e no início não era assim
porque o titular era muito agitada e
muito agressivo mesmo então acho que já
ganhou aquela confiança mais dados sobre
o bode porque chama pode por que
continue assim ele é muito parecido com
um bonde um bom mesmo é ter bem e os
chifres e como é um companheiro um
companheiro meu agora e companheiro em
inglês é bad então pode mais banda bora
bora e honesto tais body board lhe o ol
de fazer boy
ai meu deus que eu pagasse wo ai meu
deus eu estava muito agressivo não pode
não pode e não pode cuidar não cair não
cair lindo pode cair na escada o lindo
eu quero é brincadeira eu quero é
brinquedo tereré o vlog quer e brinque
der e aimar e não como agora está muito
bem é quem pode pode bole bole porque
está a fazer story morning glory a isto
eu estudo eu e meu deus os tipos de 1
muito duro e eu gostei brincadeira e eu
gosto de brincar e terry
agora olha maria ana maria eu tenho
muita força não tem muita força mesmo
olhe olhe olhe quem é o bari cagliari o
que estava fazendo no meu estúdio blog
não tem comida hora certa já fazer
acumular bruno não olhe mode árvore nos
como indo desde comer aqui folhas do
chão bola e vamos acabar o vídeo de
perto das pessoas está sendo escondido
aqui de baixo uma ordem de despejo dos
inscritos pode dizer que as pessoas
podem toque pessoal de nunca ter fumado
agora mas espero que vocês tenham estado
aqui deste vídeo já sabem disso muito
laquê neste dia isso ajuda muito que o
canal se quiserem ver mais vídeos com o
documento e também que para eu saber se
vocês gostam deste vídeos e carrega no
botão zinho subscrever pra vocês ficarem
automaticamente inscrito no canal e
acompanharem tudo deveres para lá e só
fiquei até aproximando
[Música]